so i've drawn i've drawn an arbitrary
triangle over here that we will assume
is not an equilateral triangle and let's
draw some of the interesting properties
of this triangle so let's first start
with the perpendicular bisector so let's
say this is the midpoint of this side
right over there so let me draw a little
bit closer to the midpoint looks like
right about there so this length is
equal to this length right over here and
so let me draw a perpendicular bisector
so perpendicular bisector would look
something
like that for that side now let me do it
on this side so just trying to eyeball
it this looks roughly like the midpoint
so this length is going to be equal to
this length and then once again let me
draw a perpendicular bisector so it's
going to go at a 90 degree angle i can
draw a straighter line than that
so that looks pretty good
and it is perpendicular and then you can
imagine i will do it with this side with
side a b
so that looks like the midpoint this
length is going to be equal to that
length right over there and then if we
draw perpendicular if we draw a
perpendicular
my best attempt to draw this
it looks something like that and we've
already learned that these three lines
will definitely intersect in a unique
point right over there which we call the
circumcenter so let me write it
so this right over there is our
circumcenter
this is nothing new
now let's draw the medians so the
medians go from each of the vertices to
the
to the midpoint of the opposite side so
let me draw so this is a median let me
this is a median
this is a
median
and then
this
is and all the errors in my drawing will
start to become apparent now that i'm
trying to do multiple things with it but
we know all of the medians intersect at
the centroid
so this right over here
this right over here is the centroid
now let's draw the altitudes of this
triangle
so let's draw the altitude so i'm going
to drop a perpendicular right over here
this is one altitude i will draw another
altitude so remember it's just going to
go down like this
draw another altitude it looks something
like that and then i can draw another
altitude from this side and we know it's
going to intersect at this unique point
right over here
so i'll try to draw it as neatly as i
can and this is going to be
perpendicular although the way i've
drawn doesn't necessarily look that way
and we know that this thing right over
here is called an orthocenter
ortho
orthocenter
now the whole reason why i'm doing this
and this is frankly kind of a
mind-boggling idea it's neat enough that
each of these points even exists that if
you three altitudes will intersect in
one point that the three medians
intersect in one point and have all
these neat properties and that the three
perpendicular bisectors intersect in one
point that by itself is neat enough but
what's really neat and it's maybe not
completely apparent by the way i drew it
because i just drew it freehand is that
three these three points will definitely
be on the same line if this was an
equilateral triangle they would actually
be the same point but if for any other
triangle there will be different points
and they will be on the same line which
is just kind of crazy because obviously
two points define a line but three
points being on the same line is kind of
a
you know it's it's it seems like a very
unlikely thing if you were to just guess
it and i'm going to try to draw it as
best as i can
if you were to draw this with a straight
edge ruler it would come out a lot
cleaner but these all three points sit
on this unique line that you know it
seems something special or magical about
it and because it's something special or
magical there's one famous mathematician
who tends to get all of the most special
and mathematical things named after him
because he's the guy who's really
explored these things and we call this
the euler line
euler
oiler line and i say that leonard euler
that doesn't look it looks like enter
well i think you get the idea let me
write euler
leonard euler the euler
line the i say that he gets all of the
cool and magical mystical things named
after him because he's also responsible
for
for euler's identity which is e
to the i pi is equal to negative 1. and
we prove this in the calculus playlist
and if none of this makes any sense you
don't worry we're only in geometry right
now but he gets to have all the this is
a magical thing because e comes out of
compound interest and growth and decay
exponential growth and decay i is i
squared is negative one seems this very
bizarre imaginary number pi is the ratio
of the of the di of the circumference of
a circle to its diameter and negative
one is well negative one and so euler
showed that there's a lot of reason to
believe that these these four numbers
that come from all of these different
weird realities of the world are
connected in this very tight way and he
also showed that these special points
are all on the same line which tells us
something kind of crazy and mystical
about a reality and if that is not
enough for you if you take the midpoint
on the euler line between the ortho
center and i'm not going to prove it
here i'm just going to give you a little
bit of a tidbit of it if you take the
midpoint between the orthocenter and the
circumcenter so let's take this so i'm
going to try to look at it roughly so it
looks like it's right about there so
this length
is going to be equal to this length
right over here this point that sits on
the euler line is going to be the center
of something called the nine point
circle which intersects this triangle at
nine points and we'll see it's kind of
nine interesting points so let me let me
label that as well so it's not even it's
cool enough that these three special
points are on the euler line but there's
actually four special points and
actually there's a few more than that
that are kind of interesting so that
orange point right over there is the
center
of
the nine point circle and maybe i'll do
another video
another video just on that so anyway
hopefully you found that kind of
interesting